trust your gut there's going to be times
in your life when you really want to do
something when you feel like man this is
the right thing to do you just have to
go for it even when the data says
something now so the people around you
say something else you just feel like
it's the right thing to do that's when
you have to go and do it because
otherwise one you're going to live and
regret for the rest of your life and two
there's a reason why this came to you
the reason why this idea candy wasn't
just coming out of thin air right it's
out of frustration or pain or seeing
somebody else go through a problem
there's a reason why this idea came when
you owe it to yourself to go and do it
even though it might be challenging and
so in relation to my book when I started
writing the book I want throughout a
different kind of book and I'm going to
share a little bit more but what I'm
actually doing now I wanted every page
to be its own story what I found a super
annoying with books is I'm flipping
through the pages I'm like looking at
when is this chapter going to end when
is this chapter go to a myself eight
more pages of this chapter you know I
want to go to bed or whatever it is you
ever had that experience and so I wanted
to have a book that you can pick up and
put down whenever you want it that every
page would be its own ending point and
so what I wrote was every page there's a
title at the top there's a quote from
somebody famous or quote that inspired
me and then there's a content and then
the last sentence leads to the next page
and the next page has a title right has
an inspiring quote and then more content
so wherever you are in the book you can
pick it up and put it down super easily
I also want it to be that if you went to
a bookstore and pick it up and you flip
through to the middle there's something
interesting there then you can relate to
so I showed the first draft way back
like one chapter to my publisher and the
feedback was but they didn't like the
structure they weren't hating on it but
just this wasn't the way the books were
written and that they don't usually
design things when it's at the writing
stage and that they didn't like the idea
of having a quote on every single page
it's great to have it you know every now
and then but not every page and I SAT
there and thought about and said hey you
know these guys are eight the experts or
the book guys but then you know it just
didn't feel right like I want to write
the book that I would want to read this
is the kind
format that I wish other people were
writing in so I stuck with it and the
way he did it I just continued I didn't
show another draft to my publisher until
it was basically the final draft and
maybe a little mean but we're basically
at the deadline we're changing that
structure is a major rewrite and so it'd
be a huge pain and we would miss all of
our deadlines and so I kind of forced
issue where I believe in this so much
that I'm going to make it happen this
has to be how we do it I believe in us
so strongly it's going to work we're
doing it and I think you just have to
every now and then have the guts to
stand up for what you believe in and you
know pray that it's going to work out
how was talking this morning on my
mastermind group about making slice or
presentations and often when you go to
conferences they make you use their
templates for what a presentation looks
like what your slides have to have this
information on it and I never use it I
never use the templates because most
templates suck and my slides don't suck
right I want to have amazing slides I
want to be the best speaker the best
presentation there and for to do that I
need to have amazing slides and so I
tell them I'm not using your slides I'm
using mine and that often creates you
know an issue but I always end up
getting it now the trick is you have to
deliver on it right like those slides
better be amazing this book with the
structure better work or it's my ass and
the thing that's been great to see I
know last week you guys saw the video of
everybody getting the review copies the
number one piece of peak bag that came
back was they love the structure they
love how easy it is to read they love
the quotes the love how its laid out and
that makes me feel good that's some
validation that you know what I'm doing
is working and it's great so anyway
trust your gut you get that feeling that
you want to do something even if the
data doesn't make sense than people tell
you you're stupid you gotta do it you
gotta do it even if you fail you got to
do it just to know that you tried and
you don't live you know till ninety
looking back and say I wish I gave it my
all now you have answers ok so the
nuances answered your questions I got
the papers here but before getting into
the questions I have two bits of news to
share about the book that I'm really
excited about the came from my publisher
the first one was I got an email from
our contact at penguin Random House
audio saying they decided to bring out
an audio edition of the book congrats so
this is important i asked for this
because i know a lot of you guys you
guys are asking is an audio book and I
said listen
no I don't know enough focus on the
marketing yet but I asked my publisher
and she made the contact so congrats we
got it this is a great way to reach my
readers and also an honor since they're
quite selective in what they publish
hooray so that makes you feel good so
for those you've been asking yes audio
edition coming out I'm going to insist
on reading it this is another trust your
gut you know I've listened to tons of
audiobooks when it's not the author
reading it it's just so boring it's
insanely boring remember I loved art of
the deal by Donald Trump and that pic of
the audiobook and some guy who was
extremely boring I wanted to hear Donald
Trump saying itself we're doing an audio
version it's confirmed and I'm going to
read it I don't care what happens I'm
telling them I'm reading it and I'm
excited by it second bit of news was for
the e-book since I know you guys are
asking this is gonna come out on ebook
as well so she wrote The Luxe ebook
edition we'd also like to offer deluxe
ebook this would include exclusive video
content from you we can fit about 30
minutes of video into an enhanced ebook
with the video broken up into smaller
pieces throughout the patek stomping
you'd be willing to create of course
this too is a great way to reach more
people we need the content by November
first so I need to figure out what
content i'm going to put in the video
ebook I've never heard of a deluxe ebook
with video so 30 minutes of video I'm
going to have to figure that out but
excited and so for those you've been
asking about the ebook that's coming at
two so big news week I'm excited okay to
your questions abdallah hi Evan what is
the way to link the big picture with the
small one I mean between dream and
reality thank you so I think the big
picture you need both obviously the big
picture keeps you motivated keeps you
excited I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs that's what wakes me up
and I get excited about every day the
small one the little picture is kind of
what you have to do every day and I
think the toughest part for an
entrepreneur's aware there is that
disconnect when you wake up when you're
doing work and you don't know how it
ties to the big picture that's when you
start getting discouraged and not
motivated and so you want to make sure
that the tasks you're doing I try to
check in on a regular basis you can't do
it every single day at least for me
because the checking process takes time
but you know I know that Tuesday is my
book writing day today's Tuesday we're
recording this I'm going down and I'm
going to be writing my book and today
I'm actually editing the book and I I I
know what the bigger picture is no we're
trying to accomplish with it you know it
helps with the goal of hitting a billion
entrepreneurs
but I have my big planning session at
the beginning how do I want to reach
more entrepreneurs first of all like
even having a book what am I having a
book it's not cuz I need a book because
I want to reach entrepreneurs it's
congruent with my goal to help a billion
entrepreneurs that ok what's the book
that i want to write what i'm going to
talk about then once you determine the
topic then it's how the chapters going
to be and then when you get into the
chapters in God ok what each page going
to look like the structure the format
that talk about the top and then it's
actually writing the content so when I
go on I write the content I'm not
thinking about everything else each time
because I'm ready to plan that down but
it's congruent with my goal to help a
Billy entrepreneurs when you're an
entrepreneur and you have that
disconnect then it's hard to stay
motivated and I think it's especially
important to if you do have a team to
help them see the bigger picture to help
them understand how the work that
they're doing on daily basis having an
impact is meaningful because most people
the thing that motivates them isn't the
money it's doing meaningful work and so
you want to show them that the work
they're doing is important that
programmer that you have sitting in the
back room pounding out code who never
get to talk to a customer never get to
see the results bring them front and
center let them see feedback from the
customers not just the problems in to be
fixed but the good news so that he can
go back as a man what I'm doing is
really helping people that's what people
want to feel so for yourself or your
team make sure you make that connection
on a regular basis Tamara weeks rights
in what will you replace this episode
with has to be something engaging like
this where we hear from you and talk to
you please so yeah it's been 30 some
weeks of writing book videos and now the
book is basically done and I can have to
edit it and get the feedback and send it
in we still have a year before the book
comes out we're looking at poly December
or January so almost a year my plan is
always to have it be a reflection of
what I'm doing with the book and so a
lot of you guys have been asking about
the marketing of it you
ebooks and book tours and how I'm going
to promote it and I think that's what
I'm going to transition this video
series to be is me sharing how I'm
working the book and how I'm preparing
for the launch one that helped you with
your product launches and to to kind of
show behind the scenes of what it takes
to write a book I've never seen anybody
go through this process I wish somebody
else had made this video series too so I
could get an education and if you or
anybody else watching wants to write a
book now you can know what's involved
with working with a major publisher so
that's probably what it's going to
evolve to as always I'm open to your
feedback suggestions let me know what
you want to see but I do like to
engagement the one on one answering your
questions I like walking the whole foods
with the camera people watching on the
street too so I plan to keep it up and
thank you for that Tamara I'm feeling
the love next question amber vim rights
in the say when can I leave my full-time
job as an accounting supervisor to go on
my own I'm not sure if what I'm doing is
the right path however all the jobs to
form will be revised before submitting
what are your thoughts what would you
recommend okay so advanced it's a couple
times in the channel 1 i'm not a big
believer in burning your bridges and
going all in and put in all your savings
into your company too many entrepreneurs
do that you end up broken three months
and then begging for the old job that
you have so i wouldn't recommend going
all-in what i do recommend is number one
if you have a job then make sure it's a
job where you're learning something you
see you're a accounting supervisor you
know i don't know what your business is
going to be about but if it's not
related to accounting did I go find a
new job find a job where you're going to
learn the point of taking the job is to
learn to get experience get as close to
the entrepreneur founder as possible
learn from them you know no entrepreneur
who hires you is going to say no I don't
want you to do so much work take on as
much work as possible to learn about the
industry that you want to get into try
to find a company that has 10 employees
or less where they are doing things that
you respect the comfort that you want to
be like in three five ten years and go
learn from them so you
paid to make mistakes you're getting the
paycheck you're probably paying your
bills but more importantly you're
learning you're making contacts your
understanding how the industry works and
you see if this is for you you might get
into and say you know what this is
insane I don't want to do this kind of
work and get out right so that's amazing
contacts you to learn second thing is
I'd start doing my business on the side
part time freelancing on the side
evenings weekends and start building up
experience will end up clients build
enough connections and I would leave
when I had enough money coming in for my
business to support me not go out and
you know buy expensive cars and new
houses or anything just support me pay
the internet paid the food that kind of
thing if i can get my business on the
side to that point that's when i leave
my full-time job the guelph full time on
my own next question so goals asking i
have and i enjoy your gorgeous videos
gorgeous videos i love it thank you so
cool you inspire me in many cases i want
a request you to help me recognize
what's the reason behind my belief
system how can i become a total believer
every single moment so first of all you
know you don't become a believer every
single moment i think you're setting
yourself up for failure if you think
that everybody has moments of doubt
everybody i have moments of doubt i
don't believe in myself every single
moment i think the key is creating a
routine that builds you up and support
you i've talked about environment a lot
on this channel chances are one you're
not taking enough risk to build up your
confidence the first time you do
something is scary the first time i went
dancing was scary the first time I held
this camera out in public and people are
watching me was scary right i see some
of the cool i'm going to duck and go to
the side first I was the more you do it
the less scared I get and ready for
bigger challenges so one are you doing
enough for the things that you're scared
of to boost your confidence so the next
time you're less scared in your your
degree of comfort your zone of comfort
experience every time right a lot of
people as soon as they're afraid of
something that just the cow down the
next time comes up they cower down next
time looking until you never grow so do
the things that scare you even
just a small thing a small step because
the next step becomes easier and easier
and easier next time around the second
part of that is having a environment and
a routine that builds you up and
supports you one of the things that I
found super often was I get energized
from some random occurrence right i have
a meeting here's an example i just got
off of a live hangout with Tim Schmoyer
it's going up on his account every week
on Tuesdays and I'm jazzed right like
I'm helping people that was a good vibe
I leave super excited and I would find
that I'd get those things happen my life
sporadically like by chance you know
maybe I sit down and watch a video I
read a book or listen to a song and it
gets me excited and amped up and then
I'm great for the next hour for the rest
of the day but then the next day you
start over like for me from scratch like
what am i doing why am I doing this
right and getting where's the motivation
where's the excitement coming from and
so you need to create a routine that
builds you out the mix of the best
version of yourself and for me it's one
looking at my youtube comments cuz you
guys give me love people saying I have
gorgeous videos and praising and see the
video so important to me makes me want
to go and do more because for me you
know i'm a guy walk on the street here i
am walking on the street and it's easy
to feel like the stuff you're creating
isn't important so your garments keep me
going man it's my fuel it's my energy I
surround myself with the videos that i
create the top ten the ants presses when
i create those that help my channel take
off and i created those for myself i
created those selfishly because i wanted
to have constant motivation i wanted to
start my day with this I'd be surrounded
by bigger ideas because I felt the
people around me I had done a lot more
than them and that's not that's not
trying to think that I'm some
guru or God or genius right I wasn't
inspired by the work that was around me
and so I wanted to be around bigger
thinkers I didn't have bigger thinkers
in my network so I sought them out
aspirational mentors and being around
them this is like this is a great
conversation here I'm going to share
something this is great I was riding
with my dad in the car he was going to
go get a new car he needed me to help
drive there and we're talking about the
clips that I do with Steven Kelley
steven is the CEO of sage and we do
these monthly clips and I'll send him
emails on a regular basis giving him
advice telling him what they could do
better helping him build like the future
of sage and a lot of the evils are harsh
you know not not harsh to to be
offensive but harsh saying hey the stuff
you're doing this sucks right now you
could be doing a lot better and it's a
message that that his team you know I
feel is too afraid to share with him in
a lot of cases and I guess I could say
it because i'm outside but regardless
i'll share my opinions and my dad was
talking about how do you have you know
here's here's a CEO of sage 15,000
employees runs this huge company how do
you have the courage to tell him what to
do that you're right and he's doing all
these things that are wrong and i think
about it i think for most people that
would be intimidating how do you stand
up to somebody who's done may be way
more than you for me I compared to the
people that I hang around with what I
surround myself with are people who have
accomplished way more than he has right
Steve Jobs and Kanye West's and Walt
Disney and Martha Stewart and legendary
entrepreneurs that I looked at every
single day and so it makes me put myself
in a situation where I'm always
comfortable because I'm hanging around
those guys so talking to Steven Kelley
is not a thing it's not a I'm not
nervous doing it and so your environment
matters because I think if I wasn't
doing that if I wasn't surrounding
myself with those kinds of people in
those kind of ideas that I would be
nervous if I cool I have to talk to
Stephen Kelly is a huge CEO or I'm gonna
tell him and then be safe I'd be vanilla
I'd be born if you like a lot of the
people on his team and then i would get
results i would fade I'd be wallpaper
and so your environment matters create
an amazing environment create an amazing
routine and that'll inspire you to do
amazing things you can't do great things
unless you're surrounded by greatness
mr. ferried rights isn't it kind of fun
not knowing how things will turn out but
expecting the best and then join the
process optimism wins yeah i agree you
know i love spontaneity I love life I
love the randomness I love not knowing
how it's going to work out I think a lot
of entrepreneurs are like this i think
if you know exactly how it's going to
happen it's boring right you don't want
to do it anymore and i think it's great
to have the the goal of where you want
to go like this is what I want to
accomplish here's how much revenue i
want to make or hears the impact i want
to have but it can't just be about the
goal right I like the steps I like the
process you have to enjoy the process I
want to help a billing entrepreneurs
let's say we do that through youtube I
like making YouTube video I'm not just
making YouTube videos because I want to
hit my goal I like the process I like
sitting here with the camera recording
this for you guys I like you to answer
questions that you ask I like watching
the videos and the research like I
poured insane amount of love and time
into the channel and I like it right I
wouldn't have it any other way I love it
you have to love the process if you're
just doing as a means to an end and
you're only caring about the goal then
find another goal because there are
other goals that you can do where you
enjoy the process to leading in business
leading in business leading and business
interesting i like it Congrats evan i
wish you much success with your book I
appreciate that I really do all of you
guys who leave in me comments thanking
me for the book giving me excitement I
think it's one important it's important
lesson for me because it keeps me going
like this is 30
some odd weeks let's not even a book
release or sell another a year to go and
your comments fuel me to want to keep
doing it to make me feel like this is
going to work that's an important
process I think also it's a lesson that
if there's somebody in your life who is
trying to do something bigger trying to
do something that may take a long time
to happen has a big green encourage them
give them a high five just send them a
quick email just let them know that you
care about them when that what they do
it is important because they may be
facing a moment of doubt they may be
facing a moment of crisis where they're
not sure if they should continue or not
and you're one simple email or phone
call or hi5 can make them stay on path
because you guys know how hard it is to
run a business and is trying to do
something big I so be that support
person right it does take a lot of time
let's take a lot of immature effort just
a little bit of caring and a quick reach
out can really make a dramatic impact on
somebody's life your comments have an
impact on my life and so I really thank
you guys for that next up Victor from
Brazil I hope your book goes viral and
congrats for your 200,000 subscribers
Thank You Victor it's funny it took me
like I forget six years five or six
years to get a hundred thousand and then
we hit a hundred in September and hit
200 in January added thirty five
thousand or so subscribers in January
and it's great i love it i love the
milestones i think one of my weaknesses
is that i'll celebrate enough you know
200,000 was great but i'm like a million
let's go like this isn't this isn't
enough i want to go and i appreciate all
the people who have been leaving
celebratory comments congratulate or
comments they really do mean a lot for
me and maybe i should celebrate more
maybe it's just on too i'm too ambitious
i see a bigger picture and it just feels
like a small step along the way but i
really appreciate it thank you guys so
much it means a lot to me next up long
time loyal superfan Matthew from katra
writing in to say super excited for you
Evan
Thank You Man really appreciate that I
love the transparency of the footage
it's great to see the human element that
is the core part of your process it
creates a connection with us viewers as
to the unique person we all come to
appreciate yeah it's an important thing
for me everything that I make is
personal like it's me it's my thoughts I
love the book video as a chance to
answer questions and get a little raw
right I'm just holding the camera on a
street you don't have a camera man no
fancy editing and I think it's a great
way to involve your audience your
community in the process of whatever
you're creating a lot of people think
that before they put something on it has
to be polish has to be finished inches
be an idea can't be the process the
process is value I was having a
conversation with someone in my
restaurant group and I was he was you
know his loss is trying to find his path
and encouraged him and you go along your
path documented make videos share blog
post because that's value you may not
have the answers yet you may not be able
to tell somebody how to go on their path
that you're still discovering it I can't
tell people how to write and market a
book from experience yet I can list case
studies I can look at other examples I
can hypothesize and say how I would do
it but I can't say from experience I
haven't done it yet so I'm making this
video's of process letting you tagging
along the ride and I think that could
apply to a lot of your businesses if you
show people the behind the scenes if you
tell people what you're up to why you're
doing it what the progress report is and
let people see the passion that you have
for your business and what you're all
about I think that can lead to a lot of
great results for you I think compassion
understanding authenticity is going to
be the weapon I think that's how you
stand out as an entrepreneur your
authentic I think you can't go up
against the big competition the big
players and just compete on price or
just compete on features you get paid on
passion you compete on heart and that
comes out when you are you if i look at
your website I look at your social media
I look at the stuff you post
it's probably boring it's not authentic
like make me feel the heart why did you
start this thing why is it important to
you that's how you stand out and so this
might be how now all authors promote
their books is they do a process report
update video but i think what i'm doing
here I mean I appreciate the love I
appreciate the feedback that you love it
it's nothing special it's a guy with a
camera walking on the street you could
do the same thing in your business and
start building up an audience that
people who care about you want to see
you succeed give you motivation to keep
going and give you ideas to be
successful too super helpful Matthew
goes on the right have you thought about
making it a trilogy segmenting the book
into a trilogy like Star Wars say true
to you best of luck we're all cheering
for you so I appreciate that love it's
interesting that we're talking about the
next book in a trilogy before the first
ones even finished and released what I
want to see how I want to see how
successful the book is in terms of
having an impact my big goal is impact
right if I'm investing time in something
that I wanted to have a big impact
that's always my goal going into
something if it's a minimal impact then
the time isn't worth it the juice isn't
worth the squeeze in terms of an export
I have to in mind one is easy to do one
is not so easy to do I'll leave it like
that I might hear some ideas I don't
know my voice practice i said that i
might share some ideas as i go i want to
see the value honestly like I'm taking
as it goes I think the first book I
think it'll do well I definitely has
been the labor of love in a ton of heart
and soul and there are two other options
i have in my head that I'm playing with
but let's get the first one out and
market it and in people's hands and
having an impact and then that will
worry about books two and three thank
you everybody really appreciate all the
feedback love and support I know it's
been a while so the answer questions so
these are great if you have a question
for me about my book about your bulk of
the book writing process if you want to
talk about the topic at the top of all
trusting your gut and how to do that too
leaving the comments below and I will
answer you in a future book video thank
you so much for watching I really
appreciate it and continue to believe
and i'll see you soon